my name is Silvia Tran and I'm one of
the organizing chairs for PI data la I'd
like to welcome all of you to our second
keynote for our conference to the stage
we'll be welcoming aneema Anant Kumar
she's a brand professor at computing and
mathematical sciences department at Cal
Tech also a director of research and
machine learning at Nvidia animos
research interests band theory and
practice of large-scale machine learning
in particular she's been spearheading
the development and analysis of tensor
algorithms for machine learning she's
the recipient of several awards such as
the Bren endowed chair profession
professorship at Cal Tech Alfred P Sloan
fellowship Microsoft faculty fellowship
Google research award arrow and AFOs our
young investigator Awards NSF Career
Award and several best paper Awards she
received her BTech in electrical
engineering from IIT Madras in 2004 and
her PhD from Cornell in 2009 she was a
postdoctoral researcher at MIT from 2009
to 2010 an assistant professor at UC
Irvine between 2010 and 16 a visiting
researcher at Microsoft Research New
England in 2012 and 14 and a principal
scientist at Amazon Web Services between
2016 2018 so if you can please join me
in welcoming an Iman and Kumar to lead
us through our keynote on 10 sterli a
flexible Python framework for machine
learning that would be great
thanks a lot Thank You Silvia for the
introduction and it's a pleasure to be
here and I'm very happy do you see the
community efforts here in LA and PI data
is you know really leading the forefront
there but he who hasn't heard of tensor
I know maybe that's not the right way to
frame it right so I mean it's there in
the news a lot there is tensorflow
there's tenser course right so you think
every operation in AI is a tensor
operation because of this terminology
but what I want to distinguish is the
standard linear algebra matrix
operations from tensor algebraic
operations which really expand into more
dimensions like if you think of a matrix
multiplication you're multiplying you
can multiply a matrix on either the left
or the right right so that's the only
two options but now if you think of a
three dimensional tensor you can
multiply it in three of the directions
so it's expanding on the notion of
matrix product to higher dimension and
similarly if you think of decomposing a
matrix
you know singular value decomposition is
an algorithm we all study in engineering
classes how can I expand this to a
notion of tensor right so can I think of
a tensor as sum of Rank 1 components or
can I think of this tensor as a
contraction over a lower dimensional
tensor which in the matrix case would
mean you're multiplying you're
expressing this matrix as a product of
two matrices and then you know the
dimension lawyers right that's the
notion of a low rank matrix in the case
of the tensor these two notions are
actually different when you express the
tensor as sum of Rank 1 components
that's a different notion from when you
think of it as a contraction of a lower
dimensional tensor into this higher
dimensional space so you know the matrix
is a special case of a tensor because
to second order tensor but when we
expand to higher orders we get a richer
algebraic set of operations so we can
contract in different directions we can
decompose in different ways and in fact
you can think of different notions of
tensor representations you can go to
hierarchical tensor representations that
in a way could be also thought of as how
you think of deep neural networks right
you can in the algebraic sense you can
relate the both in that way and so
that's where I want to use this talk to
distinguish the standard use of tensors
when we say transfer flow or tensor core
which is to mean there's an array of
numbers you know some data that's
represented as a multi-dimensional array
but we are still doing matrix and linear
algebra operation that's the standard
usage where as I'm asking can we take
multi-dimensional data and truly do
multi-dimensional computations on it and
that's what tends early as a toolbox
enables you to do that and it connects
to numpy so you can do with standard
linear algebra tools and expand on that
to tensor algebra or you can also have
pi torch tensor flow and MX net so you
can define it as new layers in your
neural network and now explore a new
family of architectures through this
framework in the meanwhile if you have
questions for me I mean about anything
else - like about general machine
learning I'm happy to take them while we
get this set up I think wanna make use
of this time to the fullest extent yeah
yeah sodium algae and all these
algorithms are from the quantum
simulations community for tensor
networks and they're tools like AI
tensor so currently they're not
integrated but this is what I'm talking
to people in that community like garnet
Chan at Caltech soar goal is to bring
that together but currently that hasn't
happened it it's a good question are
there any examples of tense really used
with redshift in AWS so you know
redshift is a managed database right so
to me those are all the like the way you
can bring in data and then after that
what is the actual algorithm or neural
network model that you use that's well
10 sally cumson so you can put 10 surly
into sage maker or darker eyes framework
and then run it so the question is
whether you can go from redshift to Sage
maker I think that was on the roadmap
I'm not sure if it's already there now
so with your work at Nvidia as well as
their specific Hardware optimizations
you're looking at to deal with actual
tensor are and multi-dimensional
operations yeah no that's a great
question a few years ago had a paper
with in media researcher Chris Sacca on
asking what are the new higher-order
blast primitives right so if you think
of last level one so Blas is basically
in your algebra subroutine right so
that's both for GPU and CPU the very
basis of your vector and matrix
operations so to complete that thought
so Blas one is vector vector operation
Blas 2 is matrix vector Blas threes
matrix matrix and now if you go to a
tensor it's a higher-order Blas and so
they're what we asked was can we utilize
the current primitives like batched
matrix multiplication to do more
efficient tensor contraction like you
know with a tensor again you would have
transpose operations just as in a matrix
you don't want to create new copies
that's too expensive and so we started
there and now there is a big effort to
ask different families of terms of
contractions how do we speed them up in
code can we create a you know there's a
new framework to speed that up and do it
in place yeah so I think I already gave
you the motivation for a tensor but
maybe this is a better one with Docs
right for me everything in life
dogs make it better so you know the idea
is if you're going up in the dimensions
so the scale R is zero dimensional
object it's just a point a vector is one
dimensional so it's a direction and the
length of the line right so that's a
vector and now in two dimension you know
you can think of it as rows and columns
but you can also think of it as a linear
operator it's operating on a space and
if you want to now expand it to more
dimensions similarly now it's you know
you have multiple dimensions each
dimension is called a mode so row would
be a mode column would be the other mode
so then you have the
which is the third dimension but again
you can think of it in as an operator
sense as a multi linear operator so it
extends the notion of linear operator to
more dimensions but that's the technical
usage but what does that translate when
it comes to the set of operations we can
do right and that's what I'm interested
in and what it is applicable for yes so
you know why tensors are now very
relevant to machine learning is we have
multi-dimensional data so if you think
of the image color image you have three
dimensions because you have the width
and the height and the number of
channels so if it's RGB then it's three
channels but when you go through the
layers of a neural network you are also
processing this in different ways and
that's that that's why the term tensor
flow right because you have the input as
a tensor and you have the flow of the
tensor throughout the network as the
output so that's a starting example and
now if you go to video you also had one
more dimension which is the time and now
if you go to multimodal data so if you
have what text and images your input
your dimensions then expand for instance
a visual question answering is a task
where you know you are both given the
image and the question as the input and
if you have to model text right the
number of dimensions is the number of
words in the vocabulary if you're
modeling it at the word level and so you
need to kind of think about all these
dimensions in data and so tensors are
most relevant for especially for
multimodal data because you have lots of
different dimensions coming together so
the question is we have all these
dimensions in data how do we process
them more naturally right and that's why
we need to think of tensor algebraic
operations let me just use this
even then it's not moving maybe you can
help me just move the yeah so the idea
is what is the you know processing of
data that can lead to tensors right so
even if my data is just vector data you
can think about the correlations in data
and that's a higher dimensional object
so typically we think of pairwise
correlations or covariances right so if
X is a vector you're looking at every
pair of variables and looking at how
correlated they are and that gives you
the standard correlation matrix and if
you're subtracting the mean that's the
covariance so this is standard but if
you want to go to more dimensions we
need the notion of tensor and so if
you're now looking at third order
correlations you now want to ask between
every triplet of my coordinates I want
to ask what's the correlation and so
this is operationally it'll be now a
cube alright so so these are the
correlations I want to manipulate with
so intuitively you know pairwise
correlations are the simplest a lot of
classical machine learning only operates
on pairwise data so if you'll know
principle component analysis which is to
find the low dimensional subspace where
the data lives
that's only looking at covariance right
so if you're looking at Gaussian
approximation that's only pairwise data
but as we start to have richer data and
richer models we are looking at higher
order correlations and the neural
network implicitly is doing that because
it's having all these nonlinearities but
we can also think of this explicitly
expressed to the notion of tensors right
so it can explicitly incorporate higher
order correlations in the data and so
that's the other use of tensors and so
now that we have the use of tensors to
present directly the data or the
correlations in data the next question
is what kind of operations do we do on
this right so that's where we have the
natural extensions of the matrix product
two more dimensions where now you're
operating on each mode or each direction
of the tensor right so you have like
possibly different vectors or even
matrices or higher order objects
operating on the tensor so in this case
you're multiplying the matrix with this
column vector that means you're taking
linear combination of the columns of
this matrix and now if you're
multiplying the third order tensor along
two of the directions here you see it's
a multi linear combination right and
that's why it's kind of extending the
notion of a linear operation to a multi
linear operation so it's linear in both
the red and the blue colors and so this
is a natural extension and so now you
can see you know you can directly think
about what kind of weights should I
learn across the different modes of the
tensor and you could get a nice
dimensionality reduction by operating on
it and you would lose the structure if
you convert it into a matrix so you can
always take this third order tensor
flatten it so flattening means literally
that right like you can just arrange the
matrix slice one by one into a big
matrix and operate on this but doing so
means you're destroying the structure
you're not using the fact that you know
there's the third direction that makes
it a tensor and so that's the benefit
like you can potentially keep all the
information of the different dimensions
and directly operate on that and so now
let's see how we can use these basic
intuitions and create tensor eyes neural
networks so what is one of the standard
neural networks right so for computer
vision what we have as are these
convolutional layers so you take the
image you learn
filters and you pass them through these
different layers and you have some
spatial pooling and nonlinearities so
this part is standard and then when it
comes to the fully connected layer what
we do in practice is to just two vector
eyes this so the output of a
convolutional layer is three dimensional
because it has the width and the height
and the number of channels which are due
to the layers of convolution but when
you come to the fully connected layer
you're vectorizing it you're converting
this three dimensional object into a one
dimensional object and then you're
learning what is the appropriate set of
weights to multiply it with and do some
non linearity and then in the end you
have this vector that says what is my
level of confidence of what category
this image is about right so that's the
operation we have in our standard
network but how can we go beyond so the
main thing is here we are destroying all
this three dimensional information and
directly just processing it as a one
dimensional object and can we do it as a
three dimensional operation and that's
where we propose this tensor eyes
network where we take the three
dimensional object and learn the
contraction weights directly on the
three dimensions so you see now that
these weights are more suited to the
dimensions of the data right and then in
the last layer we call it a sensor
regression because we are making this
low rank tensor the weight set of
weights we can reduce the rank of the
tensor and hence reduce the number of
parameters so the idea here is you know
if we did all this as a matrix we
wouldn't keep all the information that's
present in all the three dimensions in
this example and so what's the benefit
of this the benefit is you can have
smaller networks you can reduce the
number of parameters in your network and
still retain the accuracy so as much as
65% you can save right you can save in
terms of the number of parameters and so
this can potentially lead to better
storage you have more compact matures it
can lead to speed up because you're
operating on a smaller network and still
not lose accuracy so this is a simple
example of how by thinking about what
are the different dimensions in my data
and how does it change as I process it
through the layers of my deep neural
network and how can I try to preserve
that information and hence have a more
compact network we can best utilize the
tensor algebra so let me show some other
examples there if I manage to move to
the next slide and yeah so before that I
guess can you move one back oh yeah yeah
so the tensor Lee is a framework that
make this possible right so the
experiment I showed about the deep
tenderized networks we ran it with
tensor Li and Zhang course a fee is the
creator of tensor Li and I worked with
him last summer to further think about
tenderized algorithms and the idea is
this is a Karass like framework so
meaning that is a simple front-end api
to define tensor operations in python
and then multiple backends that you can
utilize so if you want to do scientific
operations or you know basically near
algebra operations you can use numpy and
scifi if you want to do deep learning
you have all the favorite frameworks
here but in the front end it will all
look the same right so there's a set of
basic operations that I'll show you and
then on top of it we build tensor
algorithms so what I show
was for tensile I have with deep
networks we can define those layers and
we can also define the tensile
regression which is what we did in the
last layer of the network and the
decomposition is the other framework
where we decompose the tensor in terms
of low rank components and so all this
is available with intensively so I'll
also show you some of the other
notebooks if I have time later but as an
example here with the PI torch back-end
as you can see you just set the backend
right in the beginning and in this
example here we wanted to see the tensor
is a laurent tucker tensor I mean that's
a special kind of low rank tensor and
you can just define what the what is the
rank your desire in this tensor and once
you define this you can attach the
gradients and you just set the optimizer
as in the standard neural network
training and you can run the whole loss
optimization and so in a sense it nicely
plugs into the existing deep learning
frameworks and it's very lightweight you
can easily you know bring in the new
tensor operations and integrate it with
your neural network training and so
that's an example of this yeah so this
comes to the earlier question now
suppose you know how do I actually get
the benefit of a smaller Network right
and for that you need the primitives the
tensor primitives to be defined and so
one of my earlier projects was asking
how we can do that effectively and
there's still a lot of work in this
direction to be done I mean there's a
reason why linear algebra has been used
extensively in deep learning and that's
because we have highly optimized
toolboxes with linear algebra and with
tensor algebra it's still under
development right and that's also part
of it is historic because tensor algebra
is much more involved and usually when
people in numerical analysis think about
it they require very high levels of
accuracy they always require it to be
the same answer right which is not which
is very different from what we care
about in deep learning so tensors are
np-hard like a lot of these problems are
NP hard you can't solve them exactly and
so that's where I feel that you know the
progress lag because of the hardness
whereas once we've you know adopted deep
learning NP hardness is not the
constraint right that's not a barrier to
see how they can be effective in
practice because we know even what we
think guys computationally hard problems
in the worst case instance worked pretty
well in practice and that's where I
think tensors we'll also see more of an
option because it can nicely expand upon
linear algebra operations and better
exploit the multiple dimensions in data
so I'll quickly grow through this I know
like you know there's more things I want
to cover but the main idea is this I
mean currently we stopped at Blast three
when we think of either the CUDA
libraries or the lapak right the
standard libraries for linear algebra
because that's the matrix matrix
multiplication and you they're highly
optimized to run well but with the
tensor it's like a higher order blast
because now you have this third order
tensor and let's say you want to
multiply it with matrix in one of the
directions right so this is the actual
operation but the problem is you know
you can always convert it into a matrix
operation right but you may need to like
kind of reorder the indices and if you
do the copy that's expensive you don't
want to do that and so we asked can we
think of a new primitive to do that well
right and that's where that was the
earlier work and so this is just saying
the same thing I mentioned right like
you know if you want to turn this into
just a matrix multiply operation
you have to reorder the indices and
depending on what regime you're
operating in that can be a significant
time in your competition and it also
requires extra memory so this is not
optimal and so this is where we you know
these are the details in the paper but
it turns out you can nicely use an
existing primitive called the batched
matrix multiplication and build on it as
a special case and make further
optimizations which we called strided
badge m and you can almost closely match
the performance of a single matrix
multiplication in many regimes so this
is the blue is the single matrix
multiplication and this black is the our
primitive and so the high-level take
from this is if you go in to optimize
the tensor operations there can be a lot
of benefits in fact in there now in some
things we are developing we're seeing it
can be much faster than even Blas
operations CUDA Blas operations right so
you can get the benefit of speed-up once
we have the primitives in place and
that's where we need also developers to
think at all levels of the stack how do
I expand the library how do I expand the
primitives for tensor computations how
do I think of new algorithms new ways to
move data for these tensor operations
that can make it more efficient and I
think after that we'll definitely see a
lot of benefits by using the tensor
operations so now I want to give another
examples of use of tensors in time
series and the here tensors are a
natural have a lateral use case because
time series we know can have very high
order correlation right because we know
how the past kind of affects the future
could be through higher order
correlations and that's very hard to
model and so in practice we use networks
like recurrent neural net
works or LS TMS or long short metamemory
networks but we don't really understand
right like how I mean they don't always
work and if they work you know while
they're working well and so kind of to
try to go deeper into that setting can I
get the next slide yeah so this is the
recurrent neural network right in the
standard recurrent neural network what
you're doing is you are propagating your
your state so you have this input and
you're also an output the output would
be like what is my next prediction or
the forecast or it could be something
else right so this is our standard
recurrent neural networks and we can
hear the problem is what you're doing is
you are still doing a simple first-order
Markov transition you're just going from
current state to the next state and
you're doing usually a simple
non-linearity go to go forward so this
may not capture all the higher-order
correlations in the time series and so
our question was how can we improve upon
this and this was the idea so we can
take the hidden states and we can think
about some more higher order polynomial
interactions so you can look at the
correlations between a window of hidden
States and but the challenge is if you
directly look at the correlation this
high order correlation that's a high
dimensional object right your dimensions
blow up and that's kind of overall the
intuition - you don't want to look at
high order tensors directly it's too big
an object right so instead can we
implicitly manipulate them and look at
lower anchor approximations of that and
that's what we did in this work where we
you know there's a notion called sensor
train which looks at forming a train of
the tensor modes and finding a low-rank
decomposition and so this there are
effective algorithms to do this well
and you can still capture the essence of
high order correlations that are
relevant for forecasting so by building
this into the recurrent neural network
or into the LST M cells you kind of
build in more of the inductive bias like
you know high order correlations are
needed for better forecasting can we
build that into our the network that we
are training and that's what we did here
and we see can you go to the next one we
see that for under traffic data set like
so this was the standard LST M the blue
line and the red is the tensor rise
Dallas TM which used the tensor train as
a way to capture the higher order
correlations better in our data and you
see that the long term forecasting is
much better so this is the error the
root mean square error so you can see
that for the LST M as you go predicting
into the future the arrow blows up quite
badly and this is much more control when
you do the transfer rise Dallas team
because higher order correlations are
especially relevant when you're
forecasting way into the future right
that's when you have to worry about it
more and that's showing up and same with
the climate data set yeah so as a third
example I want to show the multimodal
data so if you now have not just image
or text you have the combination you
want to ask how to combine the features
of these two networks let's say you have
some convolutional net work and some LS
TM to extract them but you still need to
combine the two to come up with the
answer so in the visual
question-answering example you want to
ask you know we want to say what the
answer is you want to combine both these
features so you can think of now forming
some you know correlation between these
two sets of features right you want to
compute the correlation between them
either first order second order and so
on so again as you keep going to higher
order correlation if we directly compute
this that's too big an object right your
dimensions blow up but can you do
different kinds of tensor
low-rank approximation x' and directly
learn this network and to end to find
what is the right way to combine these
two features like what's the right
pooling mechanism that can appropriately
capture the correlation between the
image and the text and so these are some
of the things we are exploring how to do
this there's a you know complicated
architecture but the main thing I want
you to take out of this is like we are
directly thinking of three-dimensional
tensors when it comes to image and that
needs to be pulled with one dimensional
text feature and what's the right
pooling if I will think about
correlation between the
three-dimensional object and a
one-dimensional object how do I directly
Express this right and how do I directly
capture the relevant information from
the correlation to come up with the
answer and so that's where tensors can
be very effective because you can
directly manipulate these
multi-dimensional objects so typically
what people do in visual question and
answering is they'll convert this
three-dimensional object again into a
one-dimensional object and they usually
concatenate the image and the text and
that may not capture all the relevant
correlation between the image and text
and so you may have a hard time coming
up with the answer but now by exploring
these richer set of networks that can
capture higher order correlations more
effectively but more importantly do that
in a low dimensional way still keep the
rank low so you don't have too many
parameters in your network so you can
learn more effectively and not over fit
to your training data you can use these
tensor methods to do that well and so
another topic that I another area that I
explored where tensors was to ask can I
do topic modeling effectively in fact
this was my first project with tensors I
mean we kind of happen to chance upon
tensors when we were thinking of solving
this problem
that was much that was before the deep
learning error so it's kind of coming a
full circle now and so what is the
problem with topic modeling so you have
a whole corpus of documents and you want
to ask what is the content in these
documents right what are the topics
being discussed and this is in a way
even more challenging compared to the
other problems I showed because there's
no label data so this is unsupervised
learning all you have are these text
documents you have you don't have any
example saying or in this document these
are the topics that are discussed all
right and unsupervised learning is
considered hard because maybe you don't
even know what to look for right somehow
the patterns in the data have to teaser
be teased out in a natural way and
that's can be challenging and so in this
example for instance we know that the
you know like when we read we know that
the topics that just you know by
glancing through the document you can
see will be garment information
technology and politics right there
multiple topics in the document and that
also makes it challenging traditionally
when people think of categorizing an
unlabeled data set they think of
clustering right can I put my data
points into different groups but for
document categorization that is not the
right thing because typically you don't
have one topic in a document you have
multiple topics so all these clusters
will overlap so you can't do a
clustering algorithm and so the
algorithm that or the model that we
utilized is called the latent
additionally allocation there's been
extensive work on this well it's a very
simple model but the bare you know but
that's also is power right so what it's
saying is every document has some
probability distribution over topics
let's say this is like in this example
I don't know 50% about just as 30% about
education and so on and how you're
drawing each word in the document is
from this distribution your first
drawing the top topic and then drawing a
word
according to how the words are
distributed in that particular topic
right I mean obviously English is not
generated this way because it's not just
random draws of each of the world given
the topic which is independent so you
don't have that but what's the so but
what's the benefit of this model right
it's called the back of bag of words
model and so it's only looking at the
frequencies of the words so in a way
it's ignoring all the grammatical
structure and the style and other
nuances that are maybe not the most
important things for detecting topics so
what's very important for detecting
topics is how do words Corker together
so if I can understand the co-occurrence
of words maybe that'll really help me
detect topics well and in fact even
today only this model or these class of
models are used for detecting topics in
long documents because if you go to
those deep learning kind of frameworks
they only work on very short like
sentence level once read and it's much
harder to do longer once and so that's
the benefit of the simple model because
it's asking let me look at frequencies
of words in documents and can I learn
the relationship of which words tend to
co-occur together and based on that can
I infer what the topics are and so with
that intuition we said how do I learn
that model right because what I want to
learn is this how our topics related to
words for instance under topic education
what can I expect my distribution of
words to be right and they're a
different topic maybe that distribution
of word changes and as different words
co-occur can I detect that and the and
the idea is to look at Triplets of words
how they co-occur together and then to
decompose that to answer because what is
the intuition I mean if a word Apple
let's say occurs in a document you know
it's probably a fruit or the CIM
software company right on the you know
hardware and software company right so
that's the but you don't know just by
looking at the word Apple then you say
what Apple and orange together may be
more likely to be fruit but then again
there's another company called orange
too so if you go to more such
correlations if you go to now Apple
orange and banana then yes you know most
likely this is talking about fruit but
you can't go and manually look at all
these such correlations and label these
documents right so instead this is
automatically done at scale it's looking
at all the triplets like Triplets of
words and asking what are the dominant
patterns that are coming out so if
they're prominently co-occurring
together maybe that's a topic that's
coming out from those core currencies
and that's what the tensile
decomposition does it's teasing out the
topics in an unsupervised way even when
you don't have labels of what the topics
are and that was the idea behind that
and that's expanding on the idea of
singular value decomposition so if
you've done like SVD you decompose the
matrix into Laura and components and now
you can expand the same to do with a
tensor as well and there's a lot of
algorithmic nuances of how to do this at
scale how you know if I have this very
large tensor I'm not going to form this
right because all I have is a vector of
frequencies for each document that is
how frequently do different words occur
in each document I don't want to form
that into a three dimensional object
because they'll be huge so I shouldn't
directly form that object but I should
implicitly manipulate that and get to
the tropics directly so there's a lot of
interesting algorithmic work to make
that happen at scale and this is
something we worked on and you know and
we showed that this is possible so so
there are also lots of advantages of
doing this tensor method as opposed to
other methods for topic modeling I won't
go into the details but there's a lot of
nice Theory you can sure that this is
guaranteed to converge to globally
optimal
solution under many natural conditions
that we expect to hold in practice and
so this was available on AWS age maker
so sage maker is a set of docker eyes
dal garita mess that are designed for
high performance and viola was there I
helped the team build this tensor
algorithm into LD a and we see that it's
much faster compared to open source
frameworks like mallet for topic
modeling so you get the benefit of
faster algorithm and also similarly or
even better topic coherence which is a
way to measure how good is your topic
model and so that you can see the
benefits of doing tensor algebra at
scale that you will you know you can
come up with good benefits in the end so
in the last few minutes I want to like
talk about some of the other efforts
that are happening at Caltech you know
that can make use of the tensors but
also other areas of machine learning and
control so we have this drone testing
facility where you kind of you know this
is a unique winter stting facility you
can see like ultimately you they'll be
like you know these are programmable
fans so there are about 1300 fans there
and I think the video is slow so
ultimately there should be like wind
blowing out of those fans so the idea is
we can precisely control no I think I
cut the wrong part of the video but
anyways sorry so that was kind of you
know showing like different wind
conditions and all this we can model
well and so this was supposed to play
together but somehow that didn't get
into the screen either I think it's
pretty dark here you don't see that very
well but on the left here is the
standard PID controller without learning
and it was just hovering around whereas
one that where we did the learning
landed well but I don't think you can
see very well in the screen and you can
see again it's hovering because it takes
a lot of time and here I wanted to kind
of say like there's so many things we
cannot model well in practice right
because in and the ground effect is one
of them and the drone is near the ground
it's too many aerodynamics forces that
are hard to model and whereas we can
learn from data and then improve this
and so there's a lot of rich
possibilities of taking learning
algorithms to drones and robotics and
other control systems and I see like
tensors playing a big part there with
time series and other multi dimensional
sensors yeah so to conclude tensors are
higher dimensional extensions of
matrices and we can expand the you know
set of operations we do with matrices
two more dimensions tensor contractions
are at the core of it and we can do
operations like tensor decompositions
tensor regressions and this will expand
the class of neural networks we can use
and better capture the dimensionality is
in data as well as higher order
correlations in a low-rank form that
makes it feasible to generalize better
and also have more compact networks
thank you
you